The Simpsons has been around for so long,
the series can be used to mark the passage
of time. In fact, plenty of the show's current
viewers were born after it debuted in 1989.
If you're one of these fans, check out the most
popular episode from the year you were born.
The most popular episode of The Simpsons
to air in 1989 was also the only one to
air that year. Of course, we're talking about
"Simpsons Roasting on an Open Fire," the very
first full-length episode of what is now the
longest-running show in primetime history.
It's a classic Simpsons tale about Homer bumbling
through life in order to make his family happy
and it's packed with relatable moments, hilarious
disappointments, and cutting satirical humor.
Early in the story, the Simpsons' Christmas
celebration is put in serious jeopardy when power
plant owner Mr. Burns chooses fat executive
raises over holiday bonuses for employees.
Homer doesn't tell Marge the bad news,
because he thinks he can dip into a big
jar of money she has stashed in her hair.
Unfortunately, Marge ends up using this
emergency fund on laser skin surgery for Bart
after he gets a tattoo when her back is turned.
Forced to take on a second job for the holidays,
Homer becomes a lackluster mall Santa. He only
ends up earning $13 and decides to bet it
all at the dog track, where he promptly loses
everything. But, fear not, this first Simpsons
episode has a happy ending. After the race,
the losing dog that Homer bet on jumps into
his arms and Bart asks if they can keep him.
"He's a loser. He's pathetic. He's...a Simpson."
In 1990, The Simpsons was just about the hottest
thing on television and Bart quickly became the
breakout star. So it's not surprising that
he served as the centerpiece of the show's
second-season premiere, "Bart Gets an 'F'," which
was also the most popular episode of the year.
Appropriately enough, this installment forces
Bart to reckon with his immature decisions and
bad boy ways. After faking his way through a book
report on Treasure Island, which he didn't bother
to read, and cheating off of Milhouse on a test,
the school psychiatrist tells Homer and Marge that
it would be best for Bart to repeat the fourth
grade. Dead set against it, Bart actually tries
to improve his marks, and gets class-brain Martin
to tutor him in exchange for popularity lessons.
After forcing himself to study, Bart defies
everyone's expectations and does well enough
on a history test to pass — though he
just barely scores a D minus. Still,
it was enough to earn his test a coveted place on
the fridge right next to one of Lisa's many A's.
Viewers can pick up clues from early episodes of
The Simpsons that Homer and Marge are in their
late 30s, and met at Springfield High School.
The 1991 flashback episode "The Way We Was"
provides a lot more detail by depicting the story
of Homer and Marge's first days as a couple.
The idea of a Simpsons episode set in the
70s, featuring a young Homer and Marge,
was irresistible and "The Way We Was" ended
up as the most-watched episode of 1991.
Back in 1974, high school senior Homer lands in
detention yet again for smoking in the boys' room.
Studious Marge winds up there for the first time,
because she burned a bra at a feminist rally.
When she walks into detention, it's love at
first sight for Homer, and he immediately
wants to ask her to the prom. To get close
to Marge, he hires her as his French tutor,
despite not actually taking that class.
After an undeniable chemistry develops
between them — and she accepts his prom invite —
he lets it slip that he lied about French class.
Feeling betrayed, Marge goes to the prom
with handsy nerd Artie Ziff instead,
standing up a heartbroken Homer. At the
end of an awful night for both of them,
Marge picks up Homer off the side of the road,
and they share their first, fate-sealing kiss.
While "Lisa's First Word" prominently
features Lisa as a baby, the real reason
this is the most-viewed episode of 1992 is that
it was a huge milestone in the life of Maggie.
In the run-up to this episode's airing, Fox
heavily hyped the fact that Hollywood legend
and Academy Award-winner Elizabeth Taylor
would guest star as the voice of Maggie.
Towards the beginning of the story, the Simpsons'
move into their home on Evergreen Terrace,
but that's just the first of many changes in store
for the family. Bart is also forced to contend
with a creepy clown bed that Homer made because he
needs to give up his crib for the newly born Lisa.
The new addition gets so much of his parents'
attention that Bart starts acting out and
threatens to run away. But he's stopped in
his tracks when Lisa says her first word:
"Bart." At the end of the episode, the action
returns to the present, where Homer puts Maggie
to bed, telling her he's in no rush for her to
speak because he doesn't want her to talk back.
After he leaves the room, Maggie delivers
the moment everyone was waiting for.
"Daddy"
It's no secret that Homer is
a man of simple pleasures,
especially when it comes to alcohol. But in
"Duffless," the most-popular episode of 1993,
Homer pays the price for his endless love of beer.
As the story begins, Homer sneaks out of work
to take the Duff Brewery tour with Barney.
Naturally, they both have a few samples,
rendering Barney physically unable to drive.
Homer, who didn't indulge as much
as Barney, gets behind the wheel,
and is immediately busted by Chief
Wiggum. Charged with drunk driving,
Homer is stripped of his license and forced
to attend Alcoholics Anonymous meetings.
"My name is Homer and I'm just here
because the court made me come."
"Homer, with our help you'll
never touch a beer again."
Marge, worried about Homer's addictive behaviors,
thinks giving up beer for a month might be a good
idea for him. He reluctantly agrees, and though
it's extremely difficult, he eventually succeeds.
In the process, he saves $100 and loses so much
weight that he no longer sweats while eating.
At the end of the month, Homer even resists his
urge to down a few beers at the bar. Instead,
he goes on a romantic bike ride with Marge. Let's
just hope he didn't end up taking her to Moe's.
The Simpsons' annual Halloween specials are a TV
tradition that still endures to this day. In 1994,
the phenomenon reached critical
mass as "Treehouse of Horror V,"
ranked as the most viewed episode of the year.
The episode starts with a parody of the horror
classic The Shining, where Mr. Burns hires the
Simpsons to be the winter caretakers of his remote
mountain lodge. But he makes sure to get rid of
all the beer and TV sets, sending Homer into a
murderous rage. Then in "Time and Punishment,"
Homer tries to fix the family's toaster and
accidentally turns it into a time-travel device.
After going back way too far and
squishing a prehistoric insect,
Homer zaps his way through various bizarre
timelines created by his actions, including a
Ned Flanders-ruled dystopia. The episode finishes
out with "Nightmare Cafeteria." In this segment,
Principal Skinner helps Lunchlady Doris figure
out new ways to serve the kids on a budget.
"Are you saying that you killed Jimbo, processed
his carcass, and served him for lunch?"
"Hah!"
While the owner of Springfield's Nuclear Power
Plant, Mr. Burns, is famously cruel, the 1995
episode "Who Shot Mr. Burns, Part 1" demonstrates
just how low the wicked tycoon is willing to sink.
After oil is discovered under
Springfield Elementary School,
bringing much-needed funds to the poorly-resourced
institution, Burns steals the lucrative crude with
his "slant drilling" company. Not only does he
destroy large parts of the town in the process,
including the Springfield Retirement Castle and
Moe's Tavern, he creates a monopoly on energy,
forcing everyone in the region to
get their power from Burns' sources.
By the end of the episode, Burns has
been shot by an unknown assailant,
and is barely clinging to life while sprawled out
on a sundial. Of course, this is only part one of
The Simpsons' most famous cliffhanger, which
left the world wondering "who shot Mr. Burns?"
"Well, I couldn't possibly
solve this mystery. Can you?"
"Yeah, I'll give it a shot."
Two years after earning some of its biggest
Halloween ratings ever, another Simpsons'
fright-fest, "Treehouse of Horror VII," scared up
enough viewers to rank as the top episode of 1996.
Some of the interest in this episode might have
been influenced by that year's presidential race,
which was between Bill Clinton and Bob
Dole. The Simpsons, always a satirical show,
made fun of both candidates in this Halloween
special by having recurring alien invaders Kang
and Kodos abduct the two men, take over their
bodies, and run for president in their place.
As the aliens point out, the United States has
a two-party system, so Americans have to vote
for one of them — and then wind up enslaved.
In the anthology episode's other segments,
Lisa's tooth-in-a-Petri-dish experiment leads to
a rapidly evolving society where she is worshiped
and, in the final story,
the family confronts Hugo,
Bart's monstrous twin brother, who's been
kept chained up in the Simpson's attic.
Fox was responsible for more than a few hits
that dominated pop culture in the 1990s,
but only one dared crossover with The Simpsons:
The X-Files. Bringing FBI agents Fox Mulder
and Dana Scully to The Simpsons was, at its
core, a publicity stunt, and it worked like
gangbusters: "The Springfield Files"
was the most popular episode of 1997.
One night, a very drunk Homer walks home from
Moe's Tavern and stumbles into the woods,
where he comes face to face with
something completely unexplainable:
A wispy, glowing, big-eyed creature
resembling popular depictions of aliens.
News of the encounter reaches Mulder and Scully,
and they journey to Springfield to
investigate the mysterious sighting.
Eventually, it's not the X-Files
duo that cracks the case,
but Lisa. She forces Smithers to come forward
and explain that the presumed alien is actually
the elderly and decrepit Mr. Burns. It
turns out that his weekly life-preserving
medical treatments leave him so confused and
disoriented that he wanders around the woods.
The glow is simply a side effect from
working around nuclear power for so long.
In "Bart Carny," the best-performing
episode of 1998, The Simpsons explore
the sketchy world of traveling carnivals.
When the carnival comes to Springfield and the
family decides to check it out, Bart gets himself
into trouble almost immediately. He hijacks a
car that the carnival claims once belonged to
Adolf Hitler and smashes it into a tree. To pay
for the damages, Bart and Homer become carnies.
Under the tutelage of father-son carnie duo
Cooder and Spud, the Simpson guys learn all
about fixing games and bribing police. Although,
Homer fails to properly pay off Chief Wiggum,
despite his many hints. This gets
Cooder and Spud's game shut down,
which is also where they live. Taking pity on
them, Homer invites them to stay with the family.
He soon learns that he shouldn't have
trusted the two carnies. Before long,
they temporarily assume ownership of the
house and won't let the Simpsons back in.
"You can't do this to me.
What about the carnie code?
[mocking laughter]
In "Maximum Homerdrive," the most-watched episode
of 1999, Homer is intrigued by a promotional stunt
at a steakhouse: Whoever can eat a 16-pound
steak with all the trimmings gets it for free.
He then accepts a challenge from a
long-haul truck driver named Red Barclay,
who bets Homer that he can finish the huge meal
before he does. Red is the first to polish off
his steak, but in the process, he dies of what
Dr. Hibbert diagnoses as "beef poisoning."
Homer, taking all the wrong lessons from this
experience, decides there's only one thing to do:
complete Red's last delivery
with Bart by his side. Of course,
he does this without knowing how to drive a big
rig or understanding the culture of the road.
"He wants you to blow your horn."
"Oh."
"That little punk!"
It's a little surprising that it took until
The Simpsons's 12th season for trickster Bart
to become a professional con artist. Fans
were apparently eager to experience this
foregone conclusion firsthand, as "The Great
Money Caper" was the top episode of 2000.
At the beginning of the story, a sturgeon
falls from a space station and crashes into the
Simpsons' car. After that unexpected event, Bart
and Homer decide to busk as a magic act so they
can earn enough money to fix the family car. The
scheme doesn't go according to plan and the duo
only earns sixty cents. Homer quickly loses his
patience with Bart and drives away without him.
When passersby take pity on the boy, he starts
raking in the cash without having to do anything.
After Bart takes a taxi home and buys himself a
steak dinner, both Simpson guys realize that they
could just grift people to earn money, no busking
skills required. Naturally, it all goes bad and,
eventually, Homer and Bart get caught by an FBI
agent. But even that is a ruse. The agent is,
in fact, an actor hired by Marge
to teach Homer and Bart a lesson.
The 2001 episode "HOMR" attempts to explain why
the Simpsons' dad has such a unique personality,
to put it kindly. Fans were
so eager to learn how he got
to be so Homer-like that they made it
the most-watched episode of the year.
After Homer gets a job as a medical test subject,
doctors find a crayon lodged in his brain. It
turns out that when Homer was a child he shoved
16 of them up his nose. He thought that he had
sneezed them all out but one stubborn crayon
stuck around for decades. After Homer has
it surgically removed, his unencumbered
brain finally works correctly. In fact,
Homer suddenly becomes intelligent, cultured,
and able to relate to brilliant Lisa for once.
They even go to the library together. However,
after a few ups and downs, Homer realizes that
he was much happier when he was less intelligent.
Luckily, Moe is more than willing to hammer the
crayon back into his brain and restore
Homer's previous level of intelligence.
"Extended warranty? How can I lose?"
"Perfect."
"Large Marge" from 2002 is absolutely packed with
silly sight gags, which helped it become the most
popular episode of the year. For example,
when Lisa wins a bet with Homer and gets to
choose their Daddy-Daughter Day activity, she
has them build houses for Domiciles for the
Destitute. They work alongside ex-presidents
Bill Clinton, George Bush and Jimmy Carter,
who engage in Three Stooges-esque
physical comedy and violent slapstick.
Later, at the worksite, Homer demonstrates to a
couple women how Marge birthed Bart — only for
her to drive by and think that he is flirtatiously
flexing his muscles for them. Worried that Homer
is losing his passion for her, Marge decides to
get liposuction. Unfortunately, the surgeons mix
up their patients and provide the episode with its
central plotline and its most obvious sight gag.
"What on earth have you done?
My maguppies became bazongas!"
In 2003's "I'm Spelling as Fast as I Can,"
two big events simultaneously pass
through the greater Springfield area:
A championship spelling competition and
a mania for Krusty Burger's Ribwich.
Of course, Homer gets addicted to the Ribwich, a
sandwich whose meat source is couched in secrecy.
He joins a group of "Ribheads" who travel
around to different Krusty Burger locations
according to the sandwich's rolled-out
release schedule. Homer's new adventure
in gluttony comes to an abrupt end when Krusty
announces that the Ribwich will be discontinued,
as the animal from which it's
derived has suddenly gone extinct.
Meanwhile, Lisa quickly rises through the ranks
of competitive spelling. In a surprise twist,
writer George Plimpton asks Lisa to throw the
finals to a more popular and marketable competitor
named Alex. If she goes along with the plan,
she'll receive a full college scholarship and
a "George Plimpton Hot Plate." Lisa, of course,
sticks to her high morals and announces during
the competition that she was asked to throw the
contest. She then defiantly continues to compete.
Sadly, she then misspells her word
and knocks herself out of the finals.
Still, her family is incredibly proud
of Lisa and her second place finish.
"You're the number one speller in this car or in
that car or in that car
or...don't look at that car."
Building fighting-robots is an ongoing
pastime for thousands of people,
but in the early 2000s, the pursuit enjoyed a
mainstream moment with shows like BattleBots.
The Simpsons tapped into this fad in 2004,
and it paid off. The robot-themed story "I,
(Annoyed Grunt)-Bot," , was the
most popular episode of the year.
After Homer does a terrible job
of assembling Bart's new bicycle,
he decides to make it up to him by constructing a
battle-bot to compete on the TV show Robot Rumble.
Homer's not the most talented engineer, however,
and resorts to crafting a glorified robot costume.
He places himself inside, then goes
on television and suffers through many
violent beatdowns until Bart finally
discovers what his dad has been up to.
But this doesn't stop Homer. He continues
to fight until the truth finally pops out.
"That robot has given birth to a man."
In 2005, Fox had the rights to the Super Bowl,
and gave The Simpsons the honor of airing
a special episode right after the big game.
That installment, "Homer and Ned's Hail Mary
Pass," seems like it was custom made to retain
as many sports fans as possible. And it clearly
worked, since it was the year's most watched show.
When a video of Homer doing a victory dance
after winning a carnival game goes viral,
several prominent athletes hire him to
choreograph their own celebratory dances.
LeBron James, Yao Ming, Michelle
Kwan, Warren Sapp, and Tom Brady
all put in a request, and are all
voiced by their real-world selves.
Homer's dances grow into such a cultural
phenomenon that he wins a plum gig
organizing the Super Bowl halftime show.
He recruits Ned Flanders to help him out,
seeing as how his pious neighbor has been making
a name for himself by producing violent biblical
films. For the big halftime show, Homer and Ned
re-create the story of Noah's Ark for millions of
football-loving fans. Of course, the reaction
of the viewing public was pretty predictable.
"All over America today, viewers were
outraged by the Super Bowl Halftime
Show's blatant display of religion and decency."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Simpsons
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.